This right here is a fresco by
Raphael of Plato hanging out
with his best
student, Aristotle.
And you may or may not
know that these two
fellows, along with
Plato's teacher,
Socrates, are considered the
fathers of Western philosophy.
But that's not what
this video is about.
This is actually just
a small little video
about different dates, or maybe
a better way to think about it,
different ways to specify
dates or dating mechanisms.
And so, if you were to
look up Plato's birth,
you might get either 428 or
427, but we'll go with 428.
If you were to look
up Plato's birth,
you might see it
written as 428 BC,
or you might see it
written as 428 BCE.
And the natural question is,
what's the difference here?
They both have a
BC, but this one
has an E. It's the
same year right now.
And the answer is that
these are referring
to the exact same
year in history,
but the acronyms here do
stand for different things.
BC literally stands
for Before Christ.
So if the date is
written 428 BC,
the implication is
that this is 428 years
before the birth of Christ.
We'll see in a second that
that's not exactly right,
but that's what
the implication is.
If someone writes
BCE, they're saying
something very different.
The B still stands for before.
But the CE, the C in CE does
not stand for Christ anymore.
It now stands for common.
And so the CE part
is Common Era.
Even though it's not
referring to Christ anymore--
and the intention here is so
that it's less religious than
the term "Before Christ"-- it's
still putting an importance
on Christ's birth, because it's
saying that the common era is
the time period after
the birth of Christ,
which we'll see in a
second isn't exactly right.
But there's essentially the
same exact dating scheme.
One not directly
referring to Christ, one
that is directly
referring to Christ.
Similarly, this right
here is a painting
of Christopher Columbus.
And if you were to look
up in history books, when
was his first voyage and when
did he first show up in the New
World, finding an
island in the Bahamas?
You would see it written as
either 1492 or AD 1492 or 1492
CE.
And once again, these are all
referring to the same year,
just using different acronyms.
One of them's a little
bit more religious,
or more directly
refers to Christ.
And one is a little
less religious.
So AD, some people think
it refers to after death.
It does not refer
to after death,
because if you think about
it, if you have years
before the birth of Christ,
and if you started numbering
after his death, how
would you number the years
during his life?
So AD does not stand
for after death.
It stands for Anno Domini,
which literally means,
anno means year, and domini
means lord, or the lord's.
So it's the year of the Lord
or the year of our Lord.
So it's years since.
And 1 Anno Domini would be the
year of Jesus Christ's birth.
So not after death.
It stands for Anno Domini, but
literally year of our Lord.
So years since Jesus was
born, with year one implicitly
starting with his birth.
And we'll see in a second
that's not exactly right.
CE stands for Common Era.
Once again, 1 CE is
the same thing as AD 1.
Sometimes we now write,
instead of writing AD 1492,
we'll write 1492
AD, all referring
to the exact same thing.
Now, all of these things we
refer to, when we say 428 BC it
implies 428 years before
the birth of Christ.
1492 AD, that's in the
year of our Lord 1492,
it implies 1492 years
since the birth of Christ.
But the reality
is that we're not
really quite sure
when Christ was born.
And so these aren't exactly.
Columbus didn't sail
across the Atlantic
exactly 1492 years after
the birth of Christ.
Most historians put the birth
of Christ at 7 to 2 BC or BCE,
depending on how
you want to view it.
Remember BC is Before Christ,
which is a little ironic,
because we're talking about
the actual birth of Christ.
BCE is Before the Common Era.
And they put his death at 30
to 36 AD, which is 30 to 36
in the year of our
Lord, or-- that's
what this stands
for, Anno Domini--
or in the Common Era, CE.
Now some people, they
obviously don't like BC.
They don't like the BC,
AD naming mechanism,
because it's
explicitly referring
to Christ in every year.
It makes Christ the central
figure in all of history.
So they'll say that this
is clearly too Christian.
And they would
prefer the situation,
they would prefer the less
Christian naming scheme
where you use BCE and CE.
But a lot of people would still
say, hey, look you change.
Well, you know, first
of all, some Christians
wouldn't like this that you
removed the direct references
to the birth of Christ,
or being in the years
since Christ's birth.
But even here, and they'll
say, you've removed it.
But even here, some
people would complain
that although you've made the
direct reference that this
is saying Before the Common
Era, and the Common Era,
even though you've removed
the direct reference,
it still makes Christ's birth
the central thing in all
of history.
But this is the convention
whether people like it or not.
In order to have the same
reference point and it's
too logistically difficult
to switch it this time,
everyone has essentially
settled on this.
It's really just a
matter of letters
of which naming scheme you pick.
But the whole
point of this video
is that you don't get
confused between BC and BCE.
You don't think that AD
stands for after death, it
stands for Anno Domini,
in the year the Lord,
or the year of our Lord.
And CE stands for Common Era.
But this and this are referring
to essentially the same count
after Christ, after
the birth of Christ,
or this theoretical
birth of Christ,
which we don't really know
when it actually happened.
It probably did not happen at
the beginning of 1 AD or 1 CE.
And these two things also
refer to the same direction
in the timeline.
One last thing I want to point
out is that there is no year 0.
So if you take either
of these naming schemes,
you have, so let's go
very close to the year 1.
So there's just some point, this
theoretical birth of Christ,
which was probably not the
actual birth of Christ,
but at that theoretical
point-- so New Year's,
so you have December 31 of the
previous year, all of a sudden,
now, you are on January
1 of 1 AD or CE,
depending on how you
want to refer to it.
And the year before
that was 1 BC or BCE,
depending on how you
want to refer to it.
So there is no year
0 in this scheme.
And then the last thing
I want to emphasize--
and it might be obvious to
you-- is the larger a number
you have here, the further
back you're going in time.
Because this is
saying how many years
before this theoretical
birth of Christ,
and obviously larger
numbers here, you have here,
this is the further you're
going off into the future.
And if you wanted to figure
out how many years passed
between Plato's
birth and Columbus
sailing across the Atlantic
to find the New World,
you would say, well,
look, it took 428 years
to go from Plato's birth to this
theoretical birth of Christ.
And then you have
another 1492 years
to wait until Columbus
gets his ship together.
So the total number
of years would
be-- I'll do it right
over here-- 428 years
to get to Christ
from Plato's birth,
and then you have another 1492
years to wait for Columbus.
So let's see, 8
plus 2, that is 10.
As you can see, I just wanted
to add a little arithmetic
in this video.
So 1 plus 2 plus 9 is 12.
And then we have
9, 1 plus 4 plus 4.
So 1,920 years between
Plato's birth and Columbus
sailing across the Atlantic.